كان الفراعنه يعتبرونه شريان الحياه
ولولا النيل لما كانت الحضاره المصريه
القديمه بهذه العظمه والقوه وما كانت
الدول التي نشات حضارتها على جوانبه
واطرافه ونهار النيل هو اغزر انهار الوطن
العربي لكن مع تغير المناخ والتلوث
واستغلال البشر المفرطي
الكبير
من البشر بدا العد العكسي لاطول انهار
العالم فمت مخاوف تمتد من مصر الى اوغندا
تخلق النهر الخالد سلطات المصريه اطلقت
حمله لحمايه النيل وتنظيفه من المخلفات
البلاستيكيه الجاسمه عالميه
للحفاظ على التنوع البيولوجي المائي ورفع
الوعي البيئي بمخاطر تلوث المياه
يشكل النيل في الدول العشره التي يعبرها
رئيسا للمياه والطاقه يعتمد معظم سكان هذه
الدول بشكل اساسي على الامطار والنهر في
عيشهم
في السودان حيث ملتقى الرافدين الاساسيين
للنهر النيل الابيض والنيل الازرق في
العاصمه الخرطوم يوفر النيل نصف ما
تستهلكه البلاد من الطاقه الكهرومائيه
في السنوات الاخيره واضحى اقل ب 100 مره
المستوى نهر الامازون فمع انخفاض معدل
الامطار وزياده موجات الجفاف في شرق
افريقيا قد يتراجع مستوى النيل الذي يمتد
حوضه على 10% من مساحه القاره بنسبه 70 في
المئه حسب توقعات متشائمه للامم المتحده
عند منبع النهر في اوغندا يسد النهر 80%
من احتياجات البلاد من الطاقه في منطقه
جنجا احد منابع النيل التي تبعد 80
كيلومترا عن العاصمه كامبالا يعتمد عدد
كبير من العائلات على صيد السمك لكن ضاقت
سهول عيشهم الكميات واضحه محدوده جدا بسبب
مياه المصانع العادمه التي تصب في النهر
فتتحول لونه الى بني ذكر تقرير الاتفاقيه
الحكوميه الدوليه التي تضم الدول
الافريقيه ال 10 التي يعبرها النيل ان
معدلات التلوث الصناعي في النهار تزداد
بوتيره سريعه
ومن يعيشون على تقومه اول من يدفعون الثمن